three words condemnation disrespect
disproportionate
at a news conference at st joseph church
hospital its leaders and clergy
condemned the israeli police for
friday's attack against shireen
abracalis coffin and the pallbearers
accusing them of disrespecting the
hospital grounds and finally said it was
a disproportionate use of force
the police turned into a christian
health institute
disrep disrespecting the church
disrespecting the health institute
disrespecting the memory of the deceased
and forcing the pallbearers almost to
drop the coffin
the church authorities released a
previously unseen security camera
footage of israeli police entering the
hospital
which said there was absolutely no
reason for this to have happened
its general director says all concerned
parties are now discussing what to do
next most probably court case
we are now discussing with church leader
catholic church leader and the
owners of the hospital the sisters of
saint joseph and the administration of
the hospital about the next legal action
to be taken
initially the israeli police said they
were acting on the instructions of the
family something shireen's brother who
is the family's representative denies
absolutely not we
the israeli police call me to the police
station to know to know the exact route
we are taking ask me not to have any
palestinian flags risen
during the funeral no slogans no
chanting during the funeral and i stress
that this is not only my funeral not for
a broadly only not for the berkeley
family only but it's a national funeral
everybody will participate
i can't tell you the exact number of
people who will participate
i told them that the funeral will leave
from saint joseph hospital to the greek
malachite church in jaffa gate and then
to the final
cemetery in mount zion the church
authorities in the hospital are now
weighing up their legal options the
israeli police say they will investigate
the incident that took place here on
friday and the israeli army say they are
investigating the death of shireen abu
ah
but given previous investigations no one
here or indeed members of the family
hold out any hope that that will be an
independent investigation and indeed
sharing abu ahmad's family are saying
that they would like an independent
international investigation but calls
for that so far have not been heeded
imran khan al-jazeera occupied east
jerusalem
zaha is a human rights lawyer and a
board member at betsylam it's a
non-profit group with a focus on
documenting human rights violations in
palestine she explains how the israeli
government could have could be held
accountable for storming the hospital
the fact that we are talking about
a hospital that is being operated uh by
saint joseph
by by french operation
uh in the occupied territory does impose
international obligation on the state of
israel and in any case even if we're
talking only about a regular hospital in
israel this conduct this invasion is
also illegal because entering in this
way uh to a hospital uh violating and
attacking uh patients attacking
innocents that are a that that were a
a present in the hospital we all saw the
shock of people of doctors during the
filming of and the documentation of this
video all of it is also
illegal based on international law even
if it doesn't have diplomatic
diplomatic immunity
and these are live pictures from
bethlehem in the occupied west bank the
church of nativity is holding a
commemoration service for al jazeera's
shireen abu
an hour later the event will move
outside to bethlehem square and then we
believe a few hours after that a candle
vigil will be held also in bethlehem
square at 1700 gmt it comes after
shireen's death on wednesday the 11th of
may